(clapping)
(halloween music)
- It starts with picking one.
Oh, you know already.
- [Jack] Boom.
- Oh, it's so ripe.
- Delicious, fresh-squeezed O.J.
- Now?
- [Jack] How much pulp are you
supposed to take out, the whole thing?
- Put some of that in there.
- [Jack] Like a pumpkin!
Of course, duh!
I was just taking out just enough to eat!
Alright, here we go.
Get in there, get in there! Yeah!
Don't be afraid of the
mess, that's the key.
- Now cut faces as desired.
- This is where the
artistry comes into play.
- This is also where band-aids
may need to come into play.
- No, dude. Let's keep
it super safe and sane.
- Okay. Language.
- Oh no! This is not gonna be good.
- I made you.
- You sweetie.
Look at those teeth!
- Right?
- [Jack] Damn!
- My dad's a dentist, so...
- You know what?
I was winning for a while, but then
in the home stretch you
took it to another level.
- Yours is so happy, though!
- [Jack] Let them kiss.
- We made each other!
What does it mean, internet?
(upbeat jazz music)
(bags rustling)
- So far so good.
Fold one of the squares in half
diagonally to form a triangle.
Fold that triangle in half
two more times to narrow it.
- What paragraph are you on?
What, this one is ridiculous!
I'm sorry!
- Damn, this is hard.
How much time do we have left?
What is this web?
- What are you talking about?
How did they get to the web?
- I think they skipped a paragraph.
- Okay, I'm just gonna
make a web outta this.
- Okay, I'm just gonna start taping.
And I'm the person, if
a kid comes to my door,
I'll give them just peppermints
and not actual candies.
- Peppermints are candy.
- They're not fun candy.
- No, they're a bummer.
- [Quinta] Yeah, but--
- That's like socks for your birthday.
You give a kid peppermints at Halloween.
What? No!
Use black sharpie to sketch out some..
(Jack groans)
There's my spiderweb.
I'm gonna give it to Quinta.
- Yes! Thanks, Jack!
I really admire what you did do with that.
- I did my best.
- You made something out of nothing, and..
- [Quinta] that was good.
(cheerful music)
- Take each half and
gently carve out the mouth
with a small knife.
Right?
- [Jack] No, that's good.
- Stuff the inside with a
tablespoon of sunflower butter.
- That can't be good.
Amazingly delicious.
- Yeah, you realize that the dynamics
of a sunflower seed, that there's
a sharp end and a soft end.
- Some ninjas only use sunflower seeds
to kill their opponents.
Right to the jugular.
- Oh, my God. Are you okay?
- Yeah
Let's do this. You know you want it!
- Oh, okay!
It does make a good snack!
- What does that remind you of?
- How 'bout that one?
- Stay away from that one.
There we go. Now we're talking.
You know what? It's got a sweetness.
This is probably loaded with sugar.
- Three grams.
- [Jack] Not bad.
- Not bad at all.
- Oh, per serving!
Just tell me how many grams
are in the whole (beep) thing,
'cause I'm gonna eat this whole thing.
If I were president,
we would know how much
of calories were in a case of everything.
I wanna be on the Kanye ticket in 2020.
- Black Kanye? Kanye Black?
- [Jack] It's Kanye Black.
- Yeah
- Let's not get crazy.
- Why are we using his first
name and your last name?
- West Black doesn't have
as good as a ring to it.
I've got some legislation I'd
like to push through congress.
Look at the, how many
calories of the butter
for the whole container?
'Cause that's what I want to eat.
- Kanye Black. 2016.